canadian comedian nick nemeroff has died
he was 32 years old
[Music]
i'm actually realizing right now i
forgot to do
my
opening joke uh
uh
oh okay
okay here it is
hey everyone how's it going my name is
mamarov it's great to be here going to
you guys for coming out on a saturday
night give yourselves a round of
applause for being such a good audience
i i'm going gonna be honest with you
guys that didn't really feel natural
also
there was nothing written on my hand
the comics family confirmed his death on
instagram sharing in part quote it is
with profound sadness that we announce
the sudden passing of our beloved
brother his cause of death is unknown at
this time
i just got a
little
kitten huh
his name is
butter
i took butter to the vet recently not
because he was sick or anything just
because you know
free healthcare in canada
nick's family goes on to applaud his
career success quote nick's dedication
to stand-up comedy was formidable and
produced amazing results if nick was on
a comedy show he was guaranteed to leave
with new fans and he deserved to because
comedy was in many ways his life thank
you
thank you so much for laughing at that
joke
nick became a hit among comedy crowds
with his unique delivery and a fresh
take on misdirection-driven jokes i
actually
identify and sort of feel like
a
white guy with dreads
for example i
dread the past the present
the comedian's family described him as
endlessly sweet supportive of others and
humble about his many skills and
achievements they went on to say he
lived a life doing what he loved and
that's how he'll be remembered members
of the stand-up world flooded the post
with condolences including saturday
night live's sarah sherman who wrote
funniest sweetest guy ever sarah's snl
co-star chloe feynman echoed the
sentiment calling him one of the greats
and i read that
you should talk about
what you look like
and i know what some of you are are
thinking even though i said you know my
name is nick nemeroff but in this shirt
and these you know these slacks
this wristband i kind of look like a mix
between
howard and joanne nemeroff
over the course of his career nick
performed countless shows on stage and
was nominated for a juno award for
comedy album of the year for his 2020
album the pursuit of comedy has ruined
my life he even made an appearance on
conan before turning 30. like conan said
my name is nick nemeroff and like most
people my age i am
28
no services have been announced for nick
but in lieu of sending flowers his
obituary asks mourners to donate to the
planned parenthood chapter of their
choice
[Music]
you